foreign
during our childhood we have heard the
fictional stories of robots taking over
various household courses making the
lives of humans easy peasy but if you
are not aware then these fictional
stories are turning into reality though
not in the form of physical robots but
yes in the form of computer programs and
apps with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way chat
GPT is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a
as we discussed earlier Chad jpt is the
application of artificial intelligence
and machine learning if you are looking
to get certified into Ai and machine
learning then here at simply learn we
have a certification course for you
artificial intelligence is a growing
technology and the most trending jobs
these days if you are looking to get
certified have a look at artificial
intelligence Masters program by simply
learning the course covers all the
details with the industry projects of
artificial intelligence if you see there
are number of tools covered in this
certification like numpy pandas sci-fi
spark Keras tensorflow R programming
python Scala Etc this artificial
intelligence course is in conjunction
with the IBM so what are you waiting for
have your own certification and get a
good salary hike a good career with
artificial intelligence you can check
the link in the description box below so
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply land we know that SEO rankings
depends on various factors like on-page
optimization of page optimization and
more by using chat GPT we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
SEO ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chat GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
foreign
optimized blog in this demonstration so
let's get some keyword ideas for the
blog so before that let's choose what
kind of blog we want to create I really
love traveling so let's try to create a
travel blog so for the travel blog we'll
find some good keywords
foreign
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just me good keywords to create a
blog
born with Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are a few places
like Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
foreign
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
foreign
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank foreign
places
to visit
in Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh a chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to say every number of words
like if this Blog has two thousand or
five thousand words you can just ask
chat GPT to reduce it to two thousand or
thousand words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords
to increase its reach
suggest few more relevant
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
title helps the user to click on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
foreign
title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
places to
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
log
for the
keyword
dubbed in places to visit and
okay so it is showing their relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
and the good in the query that's why
it's not representing us the correct
results
we are going to optimize our blob using
all these factors
foreign
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
add headings H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me few
interlinks
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these uh blog pages in
your website or if you have created any
of these blogs earlier do Interlink it
switch off the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above but it is also
showing the significance of interlinking
okay
moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our block
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 places to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on-page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this block
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of Kyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
the mount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
than a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
good image
title and
Alt
tag
for
image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
foreign
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
foreign
choose image
it should not repeat
choose the perfect
illustration
for
Mount Fuji
image from my
block
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of an unsplash pixels
or Shutterstock to download the image so
we can really navigate to these websites
and download some of the required image
for our blog
so we we have uh completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
or your blog page
suggest me
suggest
video ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
elbow idea is best
match
for my blog let's try to extract anyone
from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
foreign
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization
ideas
video optimizations
for
mount
Fuji video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions which we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
just me
good
thumbnail idea
foreign
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
the all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
foreign
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites which are showing
more of the trip oriented or bookings
related oriented for travel or
destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so let's check how can we get backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black butter
repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks whatever blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
is the
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters so if if it is more than
60 character you may get the dot dot
part and the title will not be clearly
visible in the search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description for the key word
stop them
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so
uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate this kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO
optimized URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add in my blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four sharing
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting
on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
backing for their web and this is again
going in symbiotic way like if they are
asking for a backlink for from your blog
you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
gate
content
in above
log so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that search engines are really in
love with the uni content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so specialism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to charge
everybody is not able to identify the
duplicate content however it is
suggesting us some of the tools like
copyscape or sideliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content
unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really not are not likely to get
searched because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the sharp GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like uh screaming frog
or Google search console where we get
the detailed report of the broken links
or 404 pages that is the dead pages of a
website
so let's wrap up from the uh view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
begin advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your content and share
it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
if you are really interested to
create one of your chat gpts or create
some of these type of AI models which
will definitely reduce the manual work
then you really need to have
the knowledge of a good knowledge of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and so if you are interested
then definitely go and have a look at
simply learns
Ai and machine learning course
so with these with this in-depth course
and the AIML certification you will be
definitely able someday to create your
own
AI models
if you see it is in collaboration with
IBM the course duration is just 11
months it is an online boot camps
and please don't delay because next
cohort is definitely starting on 16th of
February
you can see our some of the alumni they
are working in the top mncs like Google
Microsoft Amazon Deloitte LinkedIn and
much more
so what skills we are covering in this
certification is statistics supervised
unsupervised learning Python Programming
recommendation system natural language
processing deep learning reinforcement
learning and if you are aware when we
started chat GPT uh this video then it
is dependent on reinforcement and
reinforcement learning so definitely it
will help you to create your own AI
models the tools we are covering in this
certification are python tensorflow
Keras the Django flask opencv and much
more if you are interested please check
the link in the description box below so
if you like this video consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn keep watching and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here